what's up guys it's Jerry here yeah I am
cruising around town just left Ryan's
place and I'm here to talk to you about
a movie I saw over the weekend because
that's right man I haven't done a review
in a while and I gotta get back on track
stop being a slacker stop being a bum or
maybe just stop working so I saw a movie
this weekend it was a movie that I'm
I've heard a few things about I just
knew it existed more than anything and I
am talking about of course the new film
ex machina this is the movie that was
written and directed by Alex garland a
guy whose name you might remember from
some Danny Boyle movies he wrote
sunshine which is a favorite of mine he
wrote 28 days later which is favorite of
mine
much other stuff he collaborates with
Danny Boyle a lot and and you know other
people as well but um this is his debut
as writer director Alex Garland I
apologize if there's noise it's so hot
today it's sweltering the weather can't
make up its mind
but anyway see ya Alex Garland I always
enjoy when this guy pops up and I was
worried you know because um this movie
is an artificial intelligence movie and
that seems like a tricky genre
especially now that it's become so
prevalent we have the technology to pull
off some of the visual aspects of that
so now people are playing with it more
and it's you know closer on the
technological horizon than maybe it was
10 years ago so it's a frequent topic of
discussion so I was worried you know I
like this guy I don't want to see him
fail you know hoping the best from a man
here and I gotta say this movie is is
pretty incredible
I almost I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and say this might just be a perfect
movie I really loved this film so this
movie stars domhnall gleeson he's been
popping up in more and more stuff lately
he was in that movie Frank with Michael
Fassbender and this is sort of a leading
role for him as this young software
coder who is selected to basically fly
out to this remote facility where the
head of his company is testing something
and
him to help with that process the head
of the company that character's name is
Nathan played by Oscar Isaac who I
didn't even realize was in this movie
until the credits rolled he disappears
so much into the character and he looks
different you know he's got the shaved
head the big old beard so this young guy
Caleb flies out to basically help him
test this project which turns out to be
an artificial intelligence so Caleb is
called out to this facility basically to
perform a Turing test which is they sort
of explain in the movie is having a
human interact with an artificial
intelligence asking it questions talking
with it and basically looking to discern
whether or not they're talking to an
actual you know intelligent mind or just
a really good sequence of algorithms so
it's the basic gist of the movie there's
a lot more to it than that
it's it's very tense at times there's a
lot of mystery intrigue and you know
various plot developments but that's the
basic stuff and I don't want to give
away too many of the surprises but Oscar
Isaac and Donald Lisa are fantastic and
their roles you know playing two very
different guys I mean you know Donald
Gleeson it's very personable but you can
tell he feels awkward here and and
Nathan is sort of your modern you know
software entrepreneur type you know he's
kind of bro e-even you know because he's
so smart but he's also very masculine
and so that creates a very interesting
kind of uncomfortable interplay between
the two of them and then you have Ava
who's the artificial intelligence played
by Alicia vikander and she does a
fantastic job too because she's got to
play you know a robot but not a robot
you know what I'm saying it's like it's
it's that fine line between you know not
quite human
but still you know a consciousness and
she does a fantastic job as well with
that and the main plot centers mostly
around these three characters and you
know some other supporting you know
people who float in and out but mainly
it's these three and they do a fantastic
job anchoring the movie and you really
don't know who to trust after a while
and part of that you know is is really
all the performances because everyone is
really fleshed out all these
characters have so much personality and
so much life in their own very different
ways and that just on a human level
makes this movie really interesting and
then part of this also falls on the
writing too because the characters are
very defined and none of them are
entirely good or entirely bad at all and
so it makes it all the more difficult to
figure out who to trust and who not to
trust and there is no clear-cut good guy
or bad guy you have a clear-cut
protagonist in Caleb and in Domino
Gleason's character but when it comes
down to all the implications it's kind
of hard to say and that's part of what
makes this movie so interesting and I
got it you know hats off to Alex garland
because this is a really well done movie
in every respect you know from the
script you know Alex Garland's a good
writer I really like his science fiction
and his you know writing and he has a
way with this because nowadays we have
this weird thing where like because we
got so overloaded with big dumb action
movies now people are always trying to
put vague amounts of science into stuff
and sci-fi is a really big genre right
now but Alex Garland has a way of
writing where you can tell he's done his
research and you know he's actually read
beyond just the basic stuff he uses that
research and he uses the intelligent
parts of the story the way one who just
knows them might reference them he
doesn't necessarily feel the need to lay
them out in the most blunt you know turn
as possible so when you get exposition
when you get explanations it makes sense
in the plot it makes sense that the
characters would say this it doesn't
feel the need it doesn't seem to dump
anything down it trusts that you'll pick
up what you need to and I really
appreciate that because this is a very
smart movie and it's so refreshing to me
anyway to be back in a realm of science
fiction that is really about the ideas
you know it's still engrossing it's
still thrilling and there is still you
know stuff that's gonna elevate your
heart rate but it's engrossing partly
because you're thinking the whole time
which is just so awesome and there's a
lot to think about across the board of
the
a lot of really subtle choices that are
there for you to kind of pick up and and
all over there some really smart
undertones some things that really gets
you thinking and considering and stuff
and there are also certain elements of
the way people behave to each other the
way men and women behave that are sort
of brought into the table twos and then
on the other side you know of things
he's directing at this time as well and
it's not the same kind of thing but we
saw a shift a lot like this earlier in
the year with wally pfister and
transcendence and where that didn't come
together for me anyway this really does
and I got a hand it to Alex Garland
again you know it seems like he's really
learned over the years from all the
directors he's worked with what I
appreciate so much is that this doesn't
feel like it's trying to be a danny
boyle movie or is like I feel like
transcendence wanted to be a Chris Nolan
movie this movie is very confident it's
very well paced
it's very well sort of thought-out and
fleshed out it takes its time but it
also does announced a it's welcome it's
really confidently captured the
cinematography is great it's very warm
and intimate they play with light in
really interesting ways and you can tell
this is a guy who really thought about
his project and really thought about
everything and granted he does have good
collaborators too obviously but this is
a really solid entry as writer director
and it's really well written really well
captured really well edited the acting
the performances are great the music is
really cool and interesting you know
every level of this movie for me anyway
it worked
you know I part way through this movie I
got a grin on my face because I was I
even said aloud to my friends like I
love this this is fantastic and usually
when I'm saying that halfway through a
movie I'm almost worried cuz it's hard
to stick a landing you know it's hard to
end a movie and this movie didn't let me
down it's stuck every landing you know
it hit every note it needed to I can't
think of a complaint you know it's like
I get the sense of this that Alex
Garland put a lot of time and care into
the script it's thrilling without being
goofy or cheesy there's some really
beautiful
moments is really human and very rich
elements to this that are just so cool
to see you know it's interesting this in
shabby came out in such a similar time
because they do represent two sides of
the coin and I'm glad that we have this
one as well because I haven't been this
enthralled by a movie especially moving
this kind in a long time and I'm so
happy for Alex Garland and everyone
involved and I really can't recommend it
enough so if you get a chance to see ex
machina if you like science fiction at
all please go check this out between
this and and predestination earlier the
air it's been a really cool year so far
for heady sci-fi you know and I'm so
happy that that's coming back so next
not gonna definitely check it out in
theaters pay full price for this give
them some support I yeah I cannot wait
to see it again yeah so what's uh what's
something you guys would like to see
happen in modern sci-fi maybe on the
less action II side of things and so
let's talk about that and is there maybe
a writer whose vision you really enjoy
who you'd like to see break into
directing so yeah I can subscribe all
that stuff leave comments in the comment
box be nice to your fellow common tears
and also you can find all of our real
rejects stuff on Twitter and and
Facebook and Instagram I've also got
reasons to Jerry on the Twitter and the
Instagram now as well so hit me up on
the socials and until next time ex
machina is the film I am Jerry Cheers